I'm Mike I'm from Lincoln Park I'll call
Rekha from from a VA Iraq and
Afghanistan vets in America tonight
where we announced the partnership
between Lincoln Park and I a VA just by
way of like explaining kind of how we
met I think one of the places where we
met is if you think about like Lincoln
Park going to places like you know Haiti
the security level around the man has to
go up and our guys have friends who are
ex you know Delta X seals etc si at
bridges SES and these guys reached out
to other friends those friends told
other friends and also we find ourselves
surrounded by in a lot of cases that's
racket Afghanistan so that got us hockey
yeah and we had a mutual friend in
common and he hooked us up and he knew
how dedicated we were to the veterans
cause and he said Mike and the guys
might have an interest we had a meeting
a couple weeks ago and look they've
always been down for the cause you know
they've always been on the side of good
issues and they've always fought for
people and
when they heard about what was going on
the veterans community and they had seen
it for themselves it seemed like a fit
there's also a huge cultural fit I mean
Lincoln Park is really a part of our
experience for our generation especially
those of us that served in the military
we've got some serious issues going on
we got high unemployment we've got a
suicide rate that's out of control and
we need vets to get more support so
these guys are stepping up and investing
in young leaders we say they're not a
charity their investment and a lot of
them are Lincoln Park fans and they're
excited to have their power and their
movement incorporated into ours so what
we're going to do is we're taking we're
going to take video clips what's the
website again it's LP for vets calm LP
for vets calm veterans is going to be
submitting videos talking about their
stories whatever whatever you want to do
we're gonna take that stuff we're gonna
put it to a song off of our new album
which is called wasteland the album is
called the hunting party songs called
wastelands they take the videos put them
together add them together to a music
video we're gonna play that out our
shows this year we're going to you know
service that to our massive Facebook
community we got 60 plus million on
Facebook that we're going to show this
video to and raise some awareness for
the cause and the vets who need it there
are two point how many vets are 28
million 2.8 million people coming home
and home already from Iraq and
Afghanistan it's a lot of people need to
help that number is scary to me I want I
know that there's people out there who
feel for these guys who know the kind of
help that they need they know somebody
who's a vet they know people who have
gone through this stuff and these guys
need our help so let's get them the
support they need let's tell a friend
go to LP 4vets calm and submit the video
thanks very much well thank these guys
they've really stepped up in a huge way
and our motto has always been we've got
your back and Linkin Park's really
stepped up they've got IVAs back they
also kick ass and our culture's fit well
and our entire community is really
excited and grateful for this
opportunity so thank you Mike
taking part in the Lincoln Park fans
we're gonna tear it up this summer and
have a good time along the way to thank
you